hello and welcome to this video
iodine sister 1986 names oh yeah why
displaying the same ish variation very
sharp opening line in fact the line that
I have played myself quite a bit in
blitz in particular not so much internal
image assets
it's rather risky and in tournament play
you have to be a little bit it's it's an
internal play I'm not sure that I want
to have it on the board all the time
this but I tried to say yeah you're
oftentimes just giving away c4 for
somewhat unclear taking chances and it's
not so easy
quite often okay the idea of 98 by the
way was to prevent Bishop g5 pins that
was a key that's a key element in blacks
play so why does going with E 5 opening
up his bishop yeah this is a common idea
actually if white tries to divert take
here on c4 you will play d6 at the end
and he tries to make my night look bad
that is really an idea but I don't have
a 5 plate so this is actually different
I get to play of 6 okay get to play of 6
and that means after f4 which is
basically the only idea that white has I
mean otherwise I'm just material up he
has to go where for I have g6 97
that makes the whole thing I think
rather dubious if I have if I had the
pawn on f5 then it's extremely difficult
to get the knight back into the game
well yeah well here there is g6 97 and
so on this is actually a stupid movie I
should have maybe taken on e5 straight
away and then now the no other Queen is
right into unite g7 2 at 5 now white is
just a pawn down down for not much I
think now the threat is Knight f5 and to
take E 5
hmm not sure what he's doing against
that you know not happier probably about
it but okay these six is also under fire
but this is a week and can be taken can
be taken at the latest stage if I take
it now there's roopd one you can
actually argue about this idea maybe put
the knight on to c4 and then take the
pawn not sure about it
yeah don't might to trade dad yeah now
how do we play this night to see for the
night is actually not very stable on c4
I'm winning every single endgame here
minor piece endings Rukh endings they
would be fairly simpler wins and what
I'm trying now is to blunder eight I
wanted to play you five okay yeah does
this happen there when you when you
don't I wanted to play knight c6 also
and I wasn't sure what to do first
that is funny especially this is this is
why I'm not keeping my 2500 reigning and
by losing winning positions like that no
no no rematch please so yeah you just
play knight c6 and wind it's just yeah
rook f7 look at vaidhi 5 it's completely
winning four black White's piece is
terrible
and it's just a clean porn down yeah I
don't think that this that this this
sacrifice works it just doesn't work
yeah the idea is kind of well it if the
pawn is on f5 which it isn't that here
yeah this is already terrible I should
have taken actually that would have been
stronger and first get the King into
this bad position
there's even stronger as now e5 is also
weak but I'm not unhappy what I did I
mean it was a winning position there
just from blunder a8 in one move yeah
that's the only way to lose the game
give him a full look ya know just ninety
six entrant yeah and you're good you
wouldn't quite easily I think okay
thanks for watching